اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه النافذه
للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على
قطاع غزه وفيها نستضيف المحلل العسكريه
اللواء فايز دويري اهلا بك لواء دويري قبل
ان نبدا التحليل نتحول الى زميله سلام خضر
ل الحديث عن اخر التطورات الميدانيه عدد
الاصابات في صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي ارتفعت
بشكل كبير يبدو ان المعارك ضاريه في هذه
الاثناء
بالفعل المعارك ضاريه والاصابات تضع بين
يوم امس واليوم نبدا وسيله بما حدث اليوم
من داخل قطاع غزه كتائب المقاومه اعلنت
انها اطلقت صليات من الصواريخ استهدفت عده
مناطق عند غلاف قطاع غزه وسمع دوي صفارات
الانذار في مدينه عسقلان بانتظار تاكيد
اصابه عسقلان بصواريخ المقاومه من عدمه
سنذهب مباشره الى المنطقه الشماليه لان
اليوم كتائب القسام وايضا سرايا القدس
قالت انها اشتبكت وقنص قوات اسرائيليه
تقريبا في المنطقه الغربيه في الشيخ عجلين
تحديدا وتؤكد سرايا القدس وكتائب القسام
ان هناك على الاقل ثمانيه من جنود قوات
الاحتلال بين قتيل وجريح هذه في منطقه
شمال القطاع الى غرب مدينه غزه هذه
المنطقه التي تكرر اسرائيل منذ اكثر من
ثلاثه اسابيع انها انهت وجود المقاومه الى
حد بعيد واليوم تعود هذه العمليات لتقول
بان ما تعلنه اسرائيل قد لا يكون دقيقا
دوما الى خانيونس المدينه وخانيونس
المحافظه في جنوب القطاع لا تزال بؤره
الاشتباك الاعنف عند اكثر من محور اليوم
ايضا كتائب القسام تحدثت عن تفجير عبوات
واستهداف اليات وايضا سرايا القدس قالت
انها استهدفت دبابه اسرائيليه واوقعت جرحه
سنذهب الى صوره اكثر قربا لمدينه خانيونس
او للمنطقه الغربيه من خان يونس لان
الاشتباكات تتركز عند المحاور الغربيه هنا
الى حد كبير مع محاولات اسرائيليه حثيثه
لدخول المنطقه و للتعمق بشكل اعمق مخيم
خان يونس وهذه المنطقه مستشفى ناصر
ومستشفى الامل الدبابات الاسرائيليه تحاول
طبعا الاحاطه بها من جميع الجهات وايضا
تشن عليها ضربات بين الحين والاخر وهناك
تحذيرات من الام الام المتحده بخطوره
استهداف المستشفيين مستشفى الامل ومستشفى
ناصر وهما المركزان الصحيان الوحيدان
اللذان
يقدمان مساعدات طبيه واغاثه للجرحى
والاصابات في صفوف المدنيين الفلسطينيين
في المنطقه الجنوبيه بموازاه هذا القصف
ايضا تقوم قوات الاحتلال باجبار السكان
على اخلاء بعض هذه المناطق تحت تهديد
السلاح وعندما يبداون بالاخلاء مثلا مثلا
الشارع رقم خمسه عندما يطلبون من المدنيين
اخلاء هذا المكان تكون هناك بعض الابنيه
التي يتواجد فيها قناصه تابعين لقوات
الاحتلال ويقومون باستهداف السكان ليست
المنطقه الغربيه الوحيده التي تشهد
اشتباكات ايضا المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه
عند بين البلديه وبين مستشفيي ناصر والامل
هناك ايضا اجت ا باكات توصف بالعنيف بين
الطرفين وكتائب القسام تتحدث عن ان هذه
الاشتباكات تسير على مستويين المستوى
الاول اشتباك مباشر تصفه القسام انه يجري
من المسافه صفر اي احتكاك مباشر من مسافات
جغرافيه قريبه جدا وايضا هناك استهدافات
متوسطه المدى اذا ما اخذنا في عين
الاعتبار ان هذا القتال يتم في منطقه
مدنيه وفي منطقه كثيفه سكانيا وهو هناك
ابنيه يمكن ان يكون شكل هذا القتال عنيف
وضاري بالنسبه للمقاومه ولقوات الاحتلال
وايضا يوقع خسائر كبيره في صفوف السكان
المدنيين اذا ما اخذنا بعين الاعتبار
القصف الاسرائيلي بالدبابات والمدفعيه
وايضا سلاح الطائرات سلاح الجو التابع
لقوات الاحتلال كل هذا وسيله يحتاج الى
قراءه معك واللواء الدويري بالفعل وهذا ما
سنفعل شكرا جزيلا لك سلام لواء دويري في
اليوم الذي صدر فيه في قرار محكمه العدل
الدوليه الغارات مستمره المعارك كذلك
ضاريه والجيش الاسرائيلي يؤكد ارتفاع عدد
جنوده وضباطه الذين اصيبوا خلال 24 ساعه
الى
47 ما دلاله كل ذلك يعني اذا تحدثنا عن ما
هي الاسقاطات القرار محكمه لاهاي الجانب
الاسرائيلي تصريحات واضحه اولا هو ينفي من
حيث المبدا ولا بل يتهم يعني اطلق عليها
مسمى احد المسؤولين محكمه
العار وبالتالي هذا موضوع اخر لكن لابد ان
يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار هذه الامور ويجب ان
يمر بعض الوقت لانه هذا القرار ليس يشمل
الكيان لوحده يشمل كافه الدول التي تزود
بالاسلحه على سبيل المثال المانيا ذهبت
لتصر
في امام الادعاء
العام بحجه انه تكفر عن ذنب عن خطايا
اخطاء قديمه اذا الان هذه الدول التي
سترسل الاسلحه هي مشاركه في جريمه الاباده
الجماعيه وبالتالي سيكون هناك يعني حتى
اذا لم يتخذ موقف جاد من قبل
اي قيادات تلك البلدان س الشارع اعتقد انه
سيضطلع الاخر
العسكري هذه المنطقه يوجد فيها كان ثمانيه
الويه وتم سحب احد الالويه قبل تقريبا
حوالي اسبوع عده ايام لا يسحب اللواء او
الوحده من القتال الا اذا الحق بها خسائر
تزيد عن نسبه 40% يعني سواء بالمعدات او
بالافراد اي بمعنى اخر محصله القوه
الناتجه عن الاليه ومستخدم الاليه اذا
اصبحت الجاهزيه دون 60% فيجب ان تسحب ابقي
على سبعه الويه هناك الكم الرئيسي يقع في
المنطقه الشرقيه وهو لم يحقق الانجازات
المطلوبه و بالتالي كان الجهد المساند هو
الاقرب الى تحقيق النجاح فتم تعزيزه بقوات
اضافيه من منطقه القراره اوزنه وكما ذكر
سلام انه الهجوم ياخذ من الشمال الغربي
الى الجنوب الغربي الى حتى يمتد الى
الجنوب وبالتالي الهجوم كانه الان على
يعني قطاع دائره يصل الى اكثر من 150 درجه
من اصل
360 لماذا انا لم اتحدث عن المواجهه
الشرقيه لانه احدثت نقاط تماس من شمال
عبسان الجديده ومن جنوب عبا سار الكبيره
لكنها لم تستطع ان تحقق اختراق يعني تعتبر
منطقه بني السيله كانها شبه شبه مستعصيه
ولم ينجحوا وبالتالي كانت المحاوله الذهاب
الى خان يونس ليس لانها اقل استعصاء ولكن
لانه القراءه الاسرائيليه ان الاهداف
الدسمه التي تبحث عنها تتواجد فيها اقصد
تحديدا الرهائن والقيادات السنوار والضيف
وابو عبيده وغيرهم لهذا السبب هي يعني
تحاول ان تبذل كل جهد ممكن ان تدخل وتصل
الى فتحات الانفاق علها تجد القيادات او
علما ان هنا يعني نتحدث بالعالم في بعد
تحليلي افتراضي اذا اشتدت المعارك في
خانيونس اعتقد ان الانفاق طولها 70 20 م
يمكن نقلهم من مكان الى اخر لن يبقوا
مستقرين في نفس المكان ومثل ما قلنا
المعارك ضاريه الان في المنطقه الغربيه
لخان يونس من الشمال الى الجنوب وخسائر
الجيش الاسرائيلي تعتبر كبيره هناك هذه
ضراوه المعارك بالمقارنه مع كل الحشود وكل
ما تجهزوا له كلما زاد عدد القوات عن
العدد الذي يجب ان يزج به كما يقال كثر
الزحام الزحام يعيق الحراك ويعيق الحركه
الان هو عندما يحشد سبعه الويه في منطقه
في منظور التحليل العسكري لا تحتاج اكثر
من فرقه ناقص للتعامل معها هو يرسل فرقتين
زائد اذا هناك اكتظاظ في القوه وكلما زاد
عدد الاليات وعدد الافراد كلما سهل الوصول
وقتل واصابه ال العديد منهم نتوجه الان
شمالا كان لافتا اليوم لواء الدويري اطلاق
رشقات صاروخيه باتجاه عسقلان مستوطنات في
غلاف غزه بعد خمسه ايام من الهدوء النسبي
ما دلاله ذلك
الان اين ومتى وكيف هذه تعود الى القياده
الان اطلاق الصواريخ ليس كقتال من قبل
العناصر
المنفردين سواء البعض يسميها حرب عصابات
البعض يسميها مسميات مختلفه
اولئك المستوى المستوى القيادي الذي
يخولهم متدني لكن اطلاق الصواريخ من
المستويات العليا من يعني ان ان القياده
فاعله اشكرك جزيل الشكر لواء فايز دوير
الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه